[Music]
in every last drop news admitted by
desse crazy that's crazy
a woman claims that drinking her dog's
urine has helped oh [ __ ] hey but if it
actually cured it would you do it though
no what made her tried that as I said my
had acne I'll [ __ ] drink the [ __ ]
piss and the jizz wait huh because to
really like make it work different
chemical properties you drink it and you
rub the face with dog come smell like
bleach - I hope I've never smelled it
old aren't you interested scientists no
no okay oh that one's it a spark is
interesting bard wears different hats
when it's a science hat he wants to do
humans he just puts a science hat on
only only for humans and the things that
I'm interested in and I'm not interested
in dot-com oh sorry
Oh a mail come yeah well never ask that
again alright so this girl her name is
Lynn Dave a picture I have a video oh
yeah how do you even catch a dog's pee
okay please name is Lynn she's 21 she
posted this video on her Facebook trying
why the [ __ ] attention trying to give
her followers their secret to her beauty
uh she might be [ __ ] fine hope she's
trolling oh [ __ ] oh oh okay here we go
many of you have asked me how I always
look so good how my makeup always look
so perfect or how I always had this
natural glow is she joking she's gotta
be kidding
I think she's Joe that's the biggest
that's a such a good toll that's a cute
doggie to do it pretty well yeah she's
done it can you imagine like
well I think it's a magic trick and
realize did you all that's a magic trick
my talk to the press through the troll
she does she said it's gonna carry
cancer that is why it looks so much
better than the best most genius troll
I've ever met or she's [ __ ] crazy as
[ __ ] she's a freaking bed for sure she's
a great troll
I hope so yeah there has to be like a
lemonade in her sleeve she was like
wearing yeah it's a camera camera now
her sleeves are rolled up girl oh no
it's a magic chain it's gotta be it was
a pouch in her hand
oh my god yeah she's got a secret that I
don't know I saw you for yeah she's got
a like a thing in her oh okay
so the reference don't play minecraft
and watch it I know this is a two girls
one cup kind of situation she reminds me
of
okay I'm you see some nasty stuff you
guys why do you know this I don't worry
about it but sketch I'm not gonna be
driving that you know she looks a lot
like this girl who kind of was in like
our gaming community unlike youtuber
community a long long long time ago and
this girl she was a little wild like I
think her name was something like
Whitney Wisconsin or something they
looked actually very much alike oh then
she made this video I don't even want to
uh tur these words but it was like seven
or ten reasons why you should be
sleeping with your dog wait that's the
same one
I remember that I didn't want to say it
right they look so alike this looks just
like her but like different name it is
her eye makeup too oh yeah that is her
[Music]
so she [ __ ] her dog and drinks its pee
she is a freakin bad but she's in bed
with her dog
Whitney with Wisconsin returns and it's
the same dress she was wearing in this
one do you remember her name I'm pretty
memory but her name no that's Lynne or
something so I'm gonna make the
connection that's what they say their
does away the same oh [ __ ] it's the same
[ __ ] I did I just smell the pee what is
it is it dog abuse though if you're
[ __ ] your dog's the dog's dog [ __ ]
her but did it off oh my god happy it's
she got the happiest dog your dogs like
human [ __ ] more maybe I don't think so
survey after let us see them [ __ ]
blankets like law standards they [ __ ]
basketballs I mean Joe [ __ ] a pill up
but you know you see your pillow waited
to hear what the [ __ ] are you looking
for I was like product it's great you
know that doesn't have it but in between
the couch there's all when there's this
to complete cushions yeah that's like a
but find a crease in book not now though
not now
no no this was five years ago
now I moved on to bigger and better
things like chairs
bigger cat legs kidding hammocks lazy
boy Kleiner's I'm lost in this chick
please tell me it's fake though because
like it doesn't seem like anyone to turn
over yeah she's trolling I think she's a
shock troll yeah sure Oh
her how is her what was her content like
was she like very jokey
I've never seen other content from she
was known for being crazy
no I think she also had like a leaked
adult film yes with a guy to dog outfit
oh there was like rumors that someone
got their hands on that as well and she
was like don't upload it but it was all
just drama Wow
yeah like Oh three four years ago let's
say this is proven now let's say like
drinking pee really clears up or dog pee
really clear clears up your skin yes and
it's like the smoothest skin you'll ever
have but back to when you're like a baby
would you guys do it no Kyle no really
when you think about it can you come
back that's like drinking milk from a
cow oh yeah from a teeth of a cow do you
have to drink it till you die or is it
one time every day a little bit every
day it definitely is different but do
you really think about it
well cuz why is we is gross yeah it's a
waste it's like AB I don't drink either
not that I'm gonna drink either
I'm just on the bottom occurs yeah but
then what if you have like something
that's like really really bad in your
life I gotta get to just get rid of this
thing well she did say she claimed that
it can help with cancer yeah what if you
got cancer and you're like I gotta get
rid of this case cancer and the only
thing that'll fix it as dog-team
[Laughter]
I want to be a more okay so it turns out
Whitney Wisconsin I mean which obviously
didn't need this confirmation cuz it's
so obvious but Lynn Lou is her legal
name when he was gone oh I liked Whitney
Wisconsin it sounds interesting if there
was a way like if for every animals piss
that I drink I was able to get that
animals power like I could sniff like a
dog smell like a dog laughs I don't be
buff like a horse or I run like a
cheetah I would drink all the pudding
literally on the market right now
scientifically proven I would drink oh
that's a pretty dope superpower isn't
there something to do with rhinoceroses
and and like they're either their tusks
or their dick like then they grind it up
all those are fake things though they're
like folklore I'm saying like imagine
that all you gotta do is suck the piss
out of that animal and you like embody
that [ __ ] power if it's just piss I'd
do it but if I'm harming the animal and
not harming it I'm not gonna do it but
if it's just piss like a shark power
shot down takes the [ __ ] in the ocean
swims over there
you grab up the shame you pick up your
[ __ ] well I couldn't picture a shark
ping well you can pick sharks anus know
if I'm swimming in the ocean in this
shot and the shark piece it just goes
away
strong like a gorilla so every time a
girl is peeing you're like oh you're
trying to catch it
yeah taste better if it was a cold piece
instead of like a warm probably it'd be
easier yeah
did you lose the nutritional value if
you leave it in the fridge there's so
many questions they all seemed real
interested cuz imagine you don't want a
power of like a hummingbird
the hummingbird is one of the only
animals that can fly backwards drink a
bird's pee and fly oh [ __ ] yeah alright
where did you get all the powers that
you don't want like you get like a
monkey pee and then all of a sudden
you're like [ __ ] in your hand and
throwing it at your friend yeah I feel
like I could fly can find all the lice
in your hair girl mmm
TV show plot know who's opposed to
people Rob any animals of your head I'm
like turning into them there's gonna be
an underground market for like animal
pee you there's be so much traffic in
the air I would only drink bird pee and
then yeah and there'd be so much there's
so many birds I didn't even be special
but what if it was like a particular
bird like I'll be a hawk I'll kill all
you little [ __ ] might be a penguin
like I want to be in the sub-zero
temperature and not be cold and swim in
your life is that useful or Narwhal I
want to go to Antarctica find the hole
that we can go through to the other
world
what there's a hole in the for another
world in the Antarctic another
possibility of this being a reality I've
entered a fantasy before it was real you
would be made a weird PI we'll go back
to realistic powers
[Music]